a Las Vegas native working to make the
U.S ski team for the 2026 winter
Paralympics three years ago she took a
snowboarding jump on Mount Charleston
which at that time landed her in a
wheelchair but the 26 year old has
worked her way back and as Ryan Matthey
reports she's now reaching New Heights
from her Hawaiian roots to Las Vegas
Shelby estacado was a princess of hula
dancing and baseball and basketball and
any other kind of sport she could get
into I played baseball with the boys I
was always into sports that passion
Landing her on the softball team at
Bishop Gorman High School a catalyst to
the University of Tulsa and her time in
the national women's baseball team I was
on the USA baseball team uh until my
accident
February 23rd 2020 a snowboarding jump
and a crash landing I went off a jump
and I lost control my abs like started
feeling weird and numb everything just
felt numb a broken sternum and a T6
spinal cord injury her legs no longer
worked Tyler
but despite the immobility she's glided
on through adaptive sports with special
equipment she does it all most
importantly skiing she's currently in
Canada competing in the para Alpine
skiing Nationals her goal make the U.S
ski team for the 2026 winter Paralympics
I always want to prove myself wrong or
just like get better at something I
don't know like I don't know until I try
622 individuals from 45 States across
the country how many athletes Roy
Tuscany says the high fives Foundation
has helped get back into sports estacado
was one of them receiving grants for the
equipment and every Friday in March feel
good Fridays in Lee Canyon donates a
portion of Lyft sales to them to help
others like her it's got to have a goal
what is that goal that this grant is
going to provide them to do and we're
going to follow up and check in and see
how they're doing and their progression
of this I just want to get better and be
happy and I'm young I'm 26 and that's
what I enjoy ways
estacado says she was connected to high
fives within 48 Hours of that accident
the partnership with Lee Canyon has
brought in a whopping 100 thousand
dollars since 2015 the CEO says